un supermarché participatif à Tours le
troglo ce nouveau magasin ne compte que
deux salariés seuls les adhérents
peuvent venir y faire leurs courses en
échange de trois heures par mois qu'ils
devront consacrer bénévolement au
magasin par exemple faire de la mise en
rayon ou tenir la caisse un concept
original aujourd'hui avec lieu
l'ouverture l'orage Chauvet était sur
place
entre la balance qui ne fonctionne pas
et des erreurs de référencement de
produit les coopérateurs ont dû gérer
quelques imprévus
alors là je suis en train de rechercher
les prix du beurre cru fermier parce que
en fait on a
4200 références on les a toutes on a
essayé toutes les enregistrer et
malheureusement il y en a qui passent un
petit peu au travers donc je recherche
de façon à les donner à la caisse
ensuite
des imprévus qui sont normaux en ce jour
d'ouverture Alain n'est pas un
professionnel de la grande distribution
c'est un coopérateur ils sont près de
600 au troglos moyennant une adhésion de
100 euros et quelques heures de travail
par mois ils peuvent faire leurs courses
dans ce supermarché coopératif
parce que le projet me plaît et que je
suis je suis dans dans cette dans cette
petite là tout simplement parce que le
projet de supermarché
participatif le troglobe m'intéressait
par les concepts qui
[Musique]
dans tout centre et trouver des
producteurs locaux c'est pas forcément
facile c'est un super marché comme les
autres où on trouve des produits
d'hygiène et des produits locaux
par exemple on a des pâtes on a une
offre assez variée en Touraine au niveau
des tout ce qui est céréales pâtes la
crèmerie aussi les fromages
également au niveau de la viande un
volaille boeuf on a aussi par exemple du
vinaigre de l'huile et puis évidemment
des fruits et de légumes seul deux
salariés travaillent ici un tour de
force permis par le projet participatif
qui limite les charges et offre des prix
attractifs